all right so it is my pleasure to
introduce our next speaker
uh dr gabriel goldser gotti
so dr gold zergati was born in caracas
venezuela and spent most of his
childhood years on the caribbean island
off the coast of venezuela called
margarita island
his passion for genetics brought him to
obtaining his biology degree at the
universidad simon boulevard in caracas
where he subsequently graduated with
honors from the masters in biological
science program in 2012
he continued his education at tufts
university in massachusetts where he got
his phd in 2018.
up to that point his focus was to apply
genetic tools on non-model insects to
various questions in the field of
taxonomy population genetics ecology and
evolutionary biology
he did both the experimental work at the
bench in computational analysis in r
python and used several other
bioinformatics tools
at the end of his phd gabriel decided to
pursue a career only in data science
focusing on genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics
he continued his training doing a
post-doctoral fellowship at harvard
medical school and the massachusetts
general hospital cancer center working
with renowned scientists both in
bioinformatics and the cancer fields
after a year and a half he transitioned
to the biotech industry working at camp
iv therapeutics as a data scientist
continuing his journey of uncovering
mysteries in biology biological data in
the field of gene regulation
so it is my pleasure to welcome dr
goldster thank you for coming
thank you laura for that introduction
so
i'm gonna go right away and jump in uh
so the title of my talk is from the
caribbean to massachusetts and how ender
regulates expression and suppresses
replication stressing cancer i'm going
to use the
mass general cancer center and harvard
medical school template because this
project was
my main project as a postdoc although i
don't i no longer ever collaborate with
them
so
uh laura already mentioned where i'm
from i'm from venezuela just
north of uh dr papas we just spoke
um specifically i grew up in a caribbean
island and this was kind of the
um
setting that i spent my weekends
so you can imagine that growing up here
will
go get you drawn to
the ocean and be a surfer of some kind
but when i was in high school i didn't
want to be dad not even a marine
biologist i wanted to be a geneticist
and that drove me to study biology
because there was no like genetics
degree per se venezuela and when i
started uh going through all the biology
courses i was more passionate about
analyzing lots of genetic data
over everything else over like doing
pcrs or spending time in the lab
so i was so passionate that i joined the
only lab at the time there that worked
with terms of genetic data and that lab
was working with this insect right here
to
apply
uh this uh a ruler scale is a millimeter
scale so it's like roughly five six
millimeters long duct pattern
we can actually see your slides
oh sorry
no worries i forgot to
do this
okay
so
yes so these guys i have you see can you
see the laser pointer now yes
yes
yes okay so this guy here
pretty small sound fly and
yeah
uh i i have to go to the jungle tropical
jungle to capture them this is me under
this light trap here and the interest of
these insects uh was that they
transmitted a disease a parasite called
this mania right here in this
microscopic picture
so
all these work in the field and the lab
to extract dna
to get this and this is hunger
sequencing uh
not used
at least on a broader scale because we
have now next generation sequencing but
i spent tons of times analyzing this
data and this had me passionate and
going into bioinformatics so i before
the next steps i went
to do my phd here in boston
and
joined the lab that was kind of working
with insects as well with genetics
and coming from this climate to this
climate was quite a transition and
this is the insect that i work in during
my phd so it's uh the european or border
you can see the caterpillar here uh in
the stock of the corn
and the adult form here so also
extracted dna doing analysis
and
uh uncovering some uh interesting
evolution biology and population
genetics quite
this journey more on the q a section so
i will go
to the title of my talk which focuses
more on nf-41
and cancer
so
before i start with this story um i'm
i'm just gonna go and
state a disclaimer that i'm not the
typical bioinformatician that you might
find
in some
labs uh in the industrial or academic
setting but just like oh yeah give me
the data and i churn it out
and and i don't talk to the people at
the lab i'd like to collaborate a lot
with the lab and bench people and go
back and forth with them design
questions like um
try to get the experimental design right
so when it makes sense
uh when when the data comes in
it i have a better idea of how to
analyze and we don't have to go back and
forth afterwards and then say no we
cannot repeat the experiment we already
did it we spent twenty thousand dollars
on it so i prefer to be in the early
stages on it and this project uh i had
the pleasure to collaborate with
function google php who was the poster
uh postdoc fellow at the time in this
project
so
another disclaimer here uh this uh was
this project has been uh recently
published uh last year molecular cell so
you can find it there and you may find
the same figures or other or not find
the figures that i'm showing you here
because they were intermediate and they
work better on a slide than on a tiny
space on the on a figure panel on the
paper
so jumping right in i should have
started with cancer so one in eight
women in the us will develop breast
cancer specifically in her lifetime and
if it's caught early as you can see in
these bar plots
you have a pretty good chance
uh to
survive and overcome it so the problem
is that when it gets stage three to
stage four it starts to do a metastasis
and going the cancer cells can go go to
other
uh tissues or organs uh
organs like the brain lungs ovaries
major organs so we want to understand
how the metastatic process work
and
this
gets us to uh circulating tumor cells so
in the early stages when you have a
primary tumor then the this tumor can
shed into the bloodstream uh cancer
cells and these are called circulating
tumor cells or ctcs as i'm going to call
them
from now on and they can land in another
tissue or organ and and evolve into a
secondary tumor therefore uh creating
what we call mutastic
so why is cdc why are cdc's worth
studying well although you have one cdc
per billion of normal uh blood cells
patients with cpc possibly samples in
the blood have worse prognosis and cpcs
may provide a real-time non-invasive
approach for tumor characterization and
personalized therapy so studying these
sdtcs can further their own
understanding of the metastatic process
and identify key drug targets to prevent
it
the lab that i collaborated with the
haber maheshwara lab and engh hms has
ctc derived from patients cultured in
vitro and
with a multiomics approach to understand
the transcriptomic genomic programs that
try pctcs to produce uh secondary tumors
which they started this project in 2017
uh one year prior that i joined as a
bioinformatician
so this is the initial experiment model
dr google injected
injections these ctcs that are derived
from patients for breast cancer human
patients
into these mice and of course we have
imaging uh with bioluminescent
luminescence markers to see where they
are
what uh
what other organs or tissues they land
in and they inform metastasis
and they solve sort of the cells
separating mice from humans and the in
throughput sequencing single cell
learning a taxi chipset
this is kind of a panel image of the
time progression of the mice and they
they injected uh two cell ctc cell lines
prx142
so from patient 142 and then brx82 from
another patient you can see that
starting when you inject into the heart
it goes all over the place but starts to
concentrate in some major organs in this
case the ovaries and then later also in
the brain and also at some stages of the
experiment the lungs
so we we write uh
we dive right in in the bioinformatics
of it
transcriptomics so if if you see on the
right the u map here um of the
transcriptomics you see that i draw
three clusters and this first cluster
has like the pre-injections so cells
before being injected into the
clustering of the mice and initial
samples just after um
the injection cluster here and then in
later stages from the first two weeks
they cluster here so the transcendent
and then after
so transcriptomic programs change over
time and when we compare in volcano
plots the pre-injection per
three we found this little guy here this
gene enter 41 which is in the title of
the talk so i will try to explain the
logic
of of the of why we focus on this guy
first you see it's highly enriched
when comparing day 30 or more samples
and pre-injection samples
we also looked at the chromatin
accessibility using atax sequencing
and here you have a correlation plot of
the samples we look of overall samples
how do they look in similar or different
to each other and you might notice that
the higher correlation is among the
pre-injection samples which are highly
identical here and here depending on the
on the cell line and there's a huge
difference between those groups and the
other groups that can in regardless of
the tissue or the day after injection so
there's a change in transcriptoming and
and epigenomics here
looking at the attacking more in depth
you can see in this heat map to the left
uh each column represents a gene and the
color is the relative accessibility
comparing pre-injection and after inject
and after injections after day two
and you see that the the
genome becomes more accessible in these
genes
here at the bottom of these heat maps
compared to the pre-injection and we
have under 41 here and another guy
that i like to call the usual suspects
in this paper foss frosty egr1 ppg2 june
you can also see them here in this plot
to the right which is a scatter plot
compare when we want to compare both
cell lines
and the the pre-injection and and day 30
and above
accessibility and here you have no
change in the center of this plot and
when you go to the corners you have more
open chromatin or
physicians again popping up and
therefore one's supposed to be false
what are these
uh these are called immediate early
genes in cancer these genes are
activating transiently in response to a
stimulus or stimuli and there are
standing response mechanics activated at
transcription levels before protein
translation these are around 40 genes
that include lr41 false speed pptg2
mixture among others
uh we annotated the regions
that
gained chromatin accessibility
and we also did cheap sequencing of
energy using the net 401 antibody
comparing pre-injection and then
the
post-injection ovary mats in this case
and bran brain metastatic cells in the
case of brx82 you might notice here this
highlighted
track section of the tracks here
you notice that for instance nf41 gains
accessibility so the attack signal is
increased
uh added
on the gene not before the promoter or
the promoter proximal region on the gene
body region it happens also in phos and
in phosphate and the chipseek also gives
us uh an while binding to the same
region
roughly at the same time
and then f41 gypsy on both of both cell
lines gave us
a binding at mostly gene body regions
which is kind of
slightly odd
if you look at the literature
for most of transcription factors
here i have two heat maps on the left of
each cell line and you notice that nr41
is at the top
because
that gain accessibility it has
it's one of the top genes that have
um gene increasing expression after the
injection
and
after doing
in uh comparing uh sorry including
atoxic post and pre-injection ratio and
also transcriptomics we found the top 16
are these genes here and the one with
the greatest scores is nfl one so we
decided to focus on what
nfr1 doing in the metastatic process
with ectc
what do we know about this gene it's
also known as number 7 or for nuclear
receptors family group a number one uh
is described uh to have positive ligands
uh these often receptors members remain
to be identified so not much information
about it the gene ontology often cites
dna binding transcription activity and
sequence specific to dna binding
and the latest paper at the time was uh
liu 2019 describing it as a key
regulator in t cell dysfunction
it has parallax and for a two and an h43
so the first question after focusing on
nf41 was is this exclusive to cdc so
we repeated the experiment with another
cell line which is not ctc it's also a
cancer centerline it's a triple negative
cell line called nda
mbt231 which i'll call m231 for short
and basically did the same thing
to done a lot of sequencing and then
plotted pre-injection versus liver
we see an f41 popping up again gaining
chromatin accessibility
exactly at the gene body
most of the gene body
targets majority of team body tigers so
it's kind of uh repeatable we also look
at the
the gene expression and there's all
this is not exclusive to cdc
one is to have an in vitro model to
further explore this mechanism and we
compare different kind of stimuli
stimuli
we we try x-ray uv heat shock
and measure the expression of some of uh
of the m231 cells and also ncfna cells
and we found that the serum acceleration
model mimic what we were seeing on the
ctcs and the m23 ones injected into the
mice the model is basically you have
cells growing in in serum baseline then
you start them for 24 hours you remove
the serum and then you replenish the
serum and take samples 30 minutes one
hour three hours and six hours after
replenishment
then you do a lot of sequencing
so looking at the data here of ataxic
again the plots comparing basal to one
hour after replenishment for both cell
banks that we tried that were not cdc's
and therefore we want gain accessibility
so
we have the same pattern here
and the only common genes that gain
accessibility between the two cell lines
well nfr1 and n43 so we stick to nf41 we
look at the expression and you see in
this bar plot that the expression keeps
ramping up and then going down
so
nf-401 also binds to gene body regions
when we do chipseek most of the regions
that define 77 percent
it's in body and there's no promoter
regions which is kind of odd so
comparing or ender for one cheap uh
chipseek done from ncf108 cells here
uh looking at the gene false and und and
comparing e2 f1 which is a transcription
factor while characterized d2f1 is
binding at the promoter or just before
the promoter regions but therefore binds
to the gene body and the downstream of
it
we also look at the gene ontology and
gsta and found that there is one of the
pathways that were enriched is
transcription for rna polymerase
promoter so that prompt us to look at
the iron april 2 chip data from these
samples and we see an overlap on it we
just see sometimes the peak of the
typical peak at the beginning of the the
promoter region of our nepal two but you
see that there's overlapping between the
nf41 and there are nipple two in the
same regions on these two genes and in
others
so looking at the seed maps
we found that uh nf41 binding perceives
the high expression we can divide the
genes into group one and group two the
ones that uh have binding at the
beginning of the serum uh
the baseline experiment and then at one
hour so those will be group two and just
before
the
we start the cells we have energon bound
to this group of genes which has phosgen
b du immediate early genes and after the
serum observation ends we start seeing
um
expression
increase in the in these genes
so we look at these three aspects
on group one and group two genes we have
nr41 protein binding here on the on red
uh
then green we have gene expression and
blue rna 2. and when we have high
protein binding of nr41
we do we have our naple 2 traveling
ratio sorry which is a measure of
how are enable 2 is transcribing
normally or it's boss is really low
which means they are nipple 2 is false
and transcription is low once we once
m41 is removed by the stress of
starvation
and then replenishment transcription and
aren't able to
go up
so it's kind of um
nf41 is kind of for these genes it's
stopping our need to pull two for
transcribing and we can see that when we
compare the genome tracks here
so this is kind of the
our model so far and therefore one is
kind of blocking our nipple two when we
have high coverage at the gene body and
then when we remove nf41
low coverage of the gene body are unable
to transcribe normally and we have more
transcripts we measure that up with rna
feet and so this is kind of like putting
a plug on a on a sink and filling it
with water the plug is nfr1 you remove
the plug you have a lot of transcript a
lot of water pouring down the pipe
this uh effect with our nipple 2 is also
found on brx 142 and vrx 82 or not in
vivo experiments so everything lines up
so
so far so we wanted to do
uh
uh
managed to crisper
one so creating an a401 knockout
cell
and we measure again a taxi chromatic
accessibility
almost no uh genes uh being outliers and
chromatin accessibility almost no change
expression on the knockouts of n401 of
the immediate early genes is through the
roof it's equivalent of when you re when
you uh
add the serum back in the mechanism the
stress is no more we have a high
expression of nh41
on our cells
and this is how the knockout cells on
this panel look like using
immunofluorescence
and and this picture gave us a
picture it's redundant to say of what's
happening to see all these multiple
nuclei
so
the loss of nfr1 the knockout
induces all genome stabilization so the
cells go haywire
so what happens to the mice if we inject
an nf41 knockout cells in vivo well we
have the m231 narcotic control cells uh
we have this size of the tumors of the
nocal cells the ones that are crisper
out the tumors are smaller so the two
more mass is significantly smaller once
we don't have nr401
in play
and
this also holds on with ctcs
onshore couldn't uh
couldn't do crispr
uh on the ctcs but he managed to do sh
iron in error for a construct so
knockdowns not knockouts and we again
see
smaller tumors on the knockdowns
compared to the not on the other to the
control cells in the same organism in
the same mice
so if we do the opposite the
overexpression of nr401 it favors
self-chlorination and tumor genesis so a
construct to overexpress nf-401 gives us
bigger tumors
so what is the mechanism behind it for
one and rnapel ii pulsing in breast
cancer method
we found out using um
s 9.63 qpcr that it starts formation of
r loops that kind of
stops rnaple2
so dripsic utilize a sequence
independent but structures a specific
antibody to
massive parallel dna sequencing and we
have more r lots uh at the beginning
when nr41 is binding and then after the
replenishment of the serum we have less
r loops
and this is confirmed also using another
type of frequency using prostig
which measures activity nuclear transfer
transcriptional processing on the eegs
we have egr egr1
cross b having high prosic signals
so this is a summary
of all of these projects so on their
basal conditions
or nfra1 is here blocking acting as the
traffic light comes on red a red sign
blocking our nipple 2 and creating these
r loops
that causes transcription of immediate
early genes
press to the mix
this nr401 is released and then we have
a lot of enable to transcribing these
immediate turkey genes
so when this stress signaling kind of
give us if i igs can be regulated by nfr
one and it becomes adapted proliferation
but if we do on control on control entry
one control replication stress there's
dna damage and metallic defects as you
saw in the picture therefore
making the cancer less adaptable to our
body
meaning smaller
tumors so this
insight on nfr1
has become a field of research in the
lab after i left because it has al you
can imagine that it has it can be they
can have a lot of application of how to
stop metastasis by controlling nr401
and with that i'll acknowledge of course
all the people involved in this project
um
mainly uh hong kong guru dr guo who did
all the amazing work
uh at the bench and gave me terabytes
and terabytes of data to have fun
and
and analyze
uh all of these data that i showed and
more that i didn't show because of
course there's there's
experiments that don't yield
uh any conclusive evidence
and of course the daniel haver and
general muharrasawa and the pi of his
lab i'm michael lawrence my postdoctoral
mentor
which is uh the head of the
computational lab in the mdh cancer
center and with that i'll be happy to
take questions
for from talk or for professional
uh questions advice career etc
great thank you so much dr goldster that
was very good
um we have a few questions for you
so
number one
how easy is it to transition from
bioinformatics to biology or
biotechnology or medicine back to
bioinformatics and vice versa are there
skills that are transferable
yes i i am a firm believer that
we have to have a strong biology
background there are a lot of
bioinformaticians that go in from
computer science or even math
that don't have that biology background
so
having a biology background is makes the
transition easier if not if you have
mainly computational skills you'll have
to make an extra effort to understand
the biology behind what's going on in
front of you in front of your computer
monitor
so going back and forth i
want some people already taught
how are you willing to learn all these
tools or these computational tools or in
the case of a computational person that
wants to go into biotech and by
information how willing are you are you
going to understand how dnr replication
works how molecules work that will give
you a lot of insight and make the
transition easier
great thank you
um what was your role in this project as
a bioinformatician
well i was a lead bioinformatician so i
i got the data from the sequencing
facility
to
the plots and the vapor that
you saw on the slides and you can see
uh of course the project had
already other my information is working
tangentially but when it started the
fellowship they gave me this and they
especially i remember this my uh michael
lawrence told me this is kind of a
fishing expedition we want to see what's
in this
massive amount of data
and the the role that i play as i say is
going back and forth with dr ghoul
to figure out
what
interesting questions could be asked
from this experiment so that's how i i
describe my role in it
great thank you i think we have time for
one final question so
how useful was the experience you had
working on this project uh for your
current career
well i think
that uh this
was
so first of all all the like uh
undergrad masters phd prepared me gave
me the basic skills to jump into this
postdoctoral uh fellowship but this
project was basically what i think it
landed me my job in industry because i
was working with insects as you remember
at the beginning of my talk it's working
with insects so some people in the
industry are like oh well but you know
that i'm sorry we
about humans so they're a little bit
hesitant once i made that like jump to
human and dna is dna like it's the same
four bases in the case of dna same for
basis in the case of rna
regardless of the system
but that jump
and all these new technologies i don't
know if the people hearing or making the
questions are familiar with a taxi
pro seek
drip seek i wasn't familiar with those
until i started with these projects so
basically that they needed the skills to
go into a a more fast-paced environment
in industry um and and work with
like the
technologies that are just
being uh developed like in a matter of
months and be able to implement
them
into the
insights that we need in the company
great well thank you again that was a
very informative talk i really
appreciate you taking the time to come
and speak with us today
thank you for having me laura
of course